hello folks how's it going this is
rational science the only site on the
internet that does physics rationally
everybody else does mathematics they
move Concepts around
uh anyways uh today we're going to be
talking a little bit about Extinction
our Countdown to Extinction topics
related to that we're gonna do physics
we're going to do very exciting the most
exciting subject you can think of
Direction
you might say Bill can't you think of
anything more exciting than that
yeah it's a quite an exciting subject so
stick around uh then we're gonna look at
something that this or science critic
uh came up with I'm gonna look at
something that he criticized and we're
going to address that and finally we're
going to open up the floor for questions
uh people who ask questions and made
common since last time okay uh let's go
with the extinction segment this is the
first topic
okay and uh here it is fellow says
nationalism is a religion okay yeah I
said that the other day he agrees okay
but just because it is a religion does
not mean that we can't feel the way that
we do or advocate for uh the people who
we love okay I don't like seeing people
who look like me and think like me
get disempowered so I'm going to resist
the changes that are causing this to
happen yeah I just we were referring
primarily to the word Ukraine and
whether you should take sides that sort
of thing
this is because I love the people who I
believe to be disempowered or because it
is in my interests
and let me tell you I feel for him
because I used to be like that myself
long time ago or something I came out of
it my grandmother one day told me never
never get into politics
and I did
in fact I got into politics at a very
early age about I was about 15 when I
started taking a big interest in
politics would read the newspaper every
day and uh eventually got into communism
in my 20s early 20s and that lasted till
I was about 36. so it lasted from 15 to
20 and 30 safe we're talking about 21
years took me to
uh realize what politics is about
slow learner okay it took me more to get
out of atheism you need to be an atheist
I came out of an atheist home you know
we talked uh atheism every day at home
uh Bible study and it took me a while to
get out of that one as well I had to
think those things over so yeah it takes
a long time and all I can tell this
fellow is that you know there's very
little you can do about stuff out there
you know one thing is like like me I got
involved okay got involved in politics
uh acting actively you know involved uh
that's different than when you uh at
home you know and just watching TV
reading the news and getting all excited
for something that happens on the other
side of the world
and you get excited and you take sides
this is wrong this is right and this you
know and you and you get all excited
about maybe you don't even sleep at
nights my recommendation for all those
feelings is you know you want to solve
The World's problem very easy
turn the damn TV off
turn the radio off don't read the news
you'll solve all the world's problems
that is the solution okay so here are
some situations here I want to see if
this fellow can recommend something to
me you know he he feels for people out
there
he wants to get involved he wants to
vote maybe you know for a different
candidate okay and so here it is okay we
have on the top we have Armenia fighting
against Azerbaijan okay and they're
fighting for that little orange area
there that you see it's called nagorno
tarabakh okay so which side should you
take the one with the half moon the
corner Moon there on the right the green
ones or should you go with the blue and
red ones on the left
and how about the one on the bottom you
got the uh
Saudis the ones on the right with all
those Cannons all the good hardware and
the guys on the left are the houthis who
these who these people okay
yeah the hood is uh and so they're
fighting uh Saudi Arabia in Yemen
and that's what you see there that map
there so so who should I take sides with
there I mean should I be with the
Shiites or with the sunnis I mean what
do you think is a better bet or who do
you think is in the right because we're
talking here about you know
you're going to take the right side and
the right side not always the winning
sided apparently right it's the uh it's
a side that you know deserves to be
backed
and uh you know there's always two sides
to all these things and people take
sides immediately for stuff that doesn't
even involve them it's on the other side
of the planet you don't even know
whether it is you say that's wrong you
know I want to get involved and maybe
even pitch money maybe vote if you can
or whatever
you know and another thing is if you go
personally and you know you get a weapon
you start killing people it was on the
other side
turns out that you know your brother's
aren't fighting on the other side like
in Ukraine
and uh you know maybe he was recruited
by the German by the Russian government
and sent to the front he doesn't agree
maybe but he's forced to go to the front
because he's a soldier and they put him
a gun in his hands go go fight
and you go on the other side because you
don't agree with the Russians are you
going to the Ukrainian side you go with
a gun you kill your own brother
great
so uh look at some of those situations
uh it's easy to take sides especially
from far away
and you know kind of eat popcorn while
you watch the game you know
another thing is to get involved and
then should you get involved anyways
does it concern you
you know so that's all I can tell you my
grandmother said never get into bother
this and I did
okay she was right it just took me a
long time to figure that out okay here's
another situation here you have the
Israelites and they're fighting the
Palestinians
and uh whose side should you take there
I mean maybe the uh Palestinians are
gorillas you know they're terrorists
maybe the other guys are abusing with
their apartheid
who whose side should you take
does it concern you are you uh uh you
know a Jew or are you a um a a
Palestinian you know whose side should
you take
you know and then this War's been going
on at least you know I would say since
the Baltimore declaration Lord Balfour
there 1917 you know they started putting
um allowing Jews to have their Homeland
and I guess that's when the whole mess
started it got worse in 1948 when Israel
became an official country
and little by little they've been
expanding and pushing the Arabs out
a lot of people say it's a United States
fifth column that's all Israel is
and the other guys on the other side you
know they they throw stones at the tanks
you say yeah that's what they should do
you know and so if if the kid you know
13 year old kid throwing a rock he got
he gets shot
killed are you going to grab the snow
and throw it and you throw it up at the
tank
is that what you want to do if you're on
the Palestinian side
okay and so here we arrive at the
Ukraine war here we have uh boats and
Moran against Al Capone okay whose side
should you take should you go with a
blue side or the red side
okay
well I don't know again uh you know
maybe you might be killing your brother
over there you got people there who are
in that war that don't want to be in
that war they're forced to be there and
probably at least I would think maybe
the majority or at least I would say
half of them don't even want to be in
there
you know especially you know it's easy
to say when you're at home but when you
see those bombs just flying close to
your area you think a little differently
you know so you got to be in that place
and the question is you know what's it
to you
uh and what I mean by that is whatever's
going to happen is going to happen
anyways With or Without You that's what
I mean so that you know for you to get
excited for something happens on the
other side of the world and that you
have no control over actually
as an individual
you know
don't get involved in politics unless
you're going to be a politician I mean
if it's your career that's that's
different but you know and you go get up
the ranks uh go up the ranks in uh in a
party with a political party well yeah
make money and influence people and and
change the laws yeah that's great but if
you're just a passive you know guy who's
at home watching the you know the TV and
you get all excited for the stuff that
happens in other parts of the world you
know just turn the TV off you'll be okay
you'll solve all the world's problems
okay and here's another side to that
okay fella says the following he says uh
I have money in Raytheon so I will
benefit from a nuclear war does anyone
want to buy my position
and I don't know if he's talking
seriously or not but he's got a point
there you know there's a lot of people
who are making profits
and this is not a a secret this is not
new anyway it's always happened you know
people profit from Wars you know and so
uh keep that in mind and uh in fact here
uh let me rub that in a little bit
here's uh one bit of news that came out
this week concerning this right
Trump blast Biden over tanks for Ukraine
and calls for an end to Crazy award to
repel Russian invasion why did he do
that well as President Biden has led the
push to help Kiev uh pumping his Maga
allies uh have repeatedly demanded the
U.S stop spending big bucks right to
help him battle the embattled nation and
they have a rep and a representative
Echo Trump's remarks calling Aid to
Ukraine a corrupt slash fund without
elaborating
in other words uh you know here you you
might be helping corruption if you said
your money over if you fight for this
cause whichever side you're on doesn't
matter
you may be fighting for someone else
who's gonna profit from it and and
you're just uh a sucker who who's doing
the work for them you know because of
your ideals okay
and here's uh the final pitch on that
one and that's uh Selinsky sacks more
than a dozen top officials amid
allegations of corruption in Ukraine and
what were they doing uh they were
accepting bribes
okay so you send these tags the you know
that's also famous the 500 hammers they
sell the army and they sell these tanks
all this uh Hardware that cost a lot of
money to build and they just give it
away kind of or put it on the tab you
know
and
these people on the other side you got
corrupt officials who you know say hey I
can make money out of all this
and they're not fighting the war they're
not the soldiers on the line they're the
guys you know uh you know in their homes
their mansions and they're making money
and here you're fighting you're rooting
for
for the people who are going to win and
it's not going to be this holder who
died it's going to be the guy who who
has the power over there in in the
government
so in a way who are you fighting for you
know uh so think about all this uh when
you take sides you know who benefits
from you taking sides you know
Paul says he doesn't believe in nuclear
weapons he says the poly says Hiroshima
and Nagasaki show that you also do not
know what you are talking about and buy
into the hype about nuclear war because
I was talking about the possibility that
you know they could uh Ukraine war could
lead to a nuclear exchange right and I'm
saying that once they press one red
button they're gonna press all the red
buttons I don't think that you can stop
that okay anyway it says the science
says both cities should have been
uninhabitable for a thousand years after
nuclear war aha yes uh yet their
population doubled in 20 years after
being nuked Hiroshima now has nine times
its 1945 population of 137
000 to two days uh 1.2 million okay how
about chernoville Bikini Island both of
these places are full of life like never
before
your fear of nukes ending humanity is
baseless
okay uh all I can tell you is that first
of all
I don't think it's uh nukes are gonna
end the world
uh if anything nukes are going to be
part of the process and that's likely at
the end you know they might press the
red button when they don't care anymore
about anything it could happen uh but
that's not the cause the cause is gonna
be
the overturning of the population of the
ecological pyramid meaning that no one's
going to produce food and it won't
matter how much money you have there
won't be food to buy whoever's got food
is going to keep it hide it
and there's gonna be a well you know
killing of not Chinese against Americans
or Russians against South Americas
Americans no it's going to be your
neighbor that's the guy you're going to
fear wherever you're at that's the guy
who's going to come after you okay local
people
and uh and then the other issue is you
know some people don't believe that
there are nukes out there and that we've
ever thrown nukes killed people and so
on this guy was talking about Hiroshima
and Nagasaki okay and
here here is some pictures you know and
I just he doesn't believe that this ever
happened you know here you see him
here's the uh Enola Gay the airplane
that took the bomb down here to Japan
okay they dropped it uh over Hiroshima
the first time second time over Nagasaki
a few days later okay
they bombed the hell out of people and
the first one there was not the original
shot but this one is this is the only
one that survived from from what
happened that day okay
and then uh here you have another uh
vision of what came after this is what
what was left
okay you can see the pictures
and Israel believes this was probably
made in Hollywood all of this
you know here you have some Japanese
just going to work a few days later and
he says well no one should have survived
there should have been zip amount of
people there and you can see that
they're walking you know and this is the
city that uh was left after they bombed
uh Hiroshima okay so just keep in mind
these are uh
these are part of the historical record
of what actually happened in those days
but this guy doesn't believe it he
thinks that all of this was probably
made in Hollywood just propaganda maybe
you know they got some actors to walk
there and whatever
and he doesn't realize that he's got the
solution in his own hands he says look
there's Chernobyl and there's a bikini
Island and so on you know the bikini I
told her and yeah people survive and
live in those places
and so maybe it's the other way around
it's not like he thinks that everybody
should be wiped out and no one can live
there for a thousand years maybe it's
the other way around maybe after the
bomb is thrown
you know some people can live there okay
so keep that in mind maybe it's not like
you think it is okay
uh so you know I've been to um
Alamogordo in New Mexico you know I went
in that region many times
uh going through last cruises and other
places there and hopefully I don't get
cancer you know I'm going through the uh
from uh the site where they through the
first nuke in what 1945 so
I don't know what to tell you guys but
no I if it were true would you say that
nobody can live there anymore for a
thousand years uh we're all in trouble
already because they've thrown some
nukes even within the United States you
know as anyone who lives nearby there I
guess
should look at his cancer his radiation
all that stuff not necessarily so
okay and so here are some of the images
from some of the survivors over there
you can see this guy's ears
if he's got ears left okay and this is a
woman her clothes got stuck to her skin
so that it just penetrated in and marked
her
you know
you can see uh some of the um the
consequences of the radiation
and this guy probably believes this is
just uh you know um all fate oh it's
done in
and you know for propaganda purposes of
some kind
and I don't know what to tell them you
know it's like those people who say well
if I didn't go to the Moon myself I
don't believe that anyone went
and so they don't believe that humans
went to the moon because I have no way
of verifying that and I haven't gone
there so
it's all a hoax
okay what can I tell you
and in another issue I found out uh
today in fact and it's uh a law that was
passed about six months ago and I was
not aware of it in Japan okay and it was
because a girl
took the ultimate uh decision okay
wrestler and um
she her fans or
enemies I guess uh said a lot of bad
things about her and so she took the
ultimate decision and because of that
they're gonna stop people from saying
bad things on the internet okay so this
is it says Japan passes Bill making
online insults punishable by jail time
in Wake of Terrace House Stars death
okay so this girl uh did the ultimate
she was only 21 or 22 years old
and now that we have laws that say be
careful what you say on the internet
and so I'm going to tell all the people
who come to this channel be careful what
you say about me okay
because I might do the ultimate too
and you're gonna be in trouble
so watch out what you say about my
mother okay
okay we uh yeah we live in a new world
so what can I say this is the world we
have you can uh they say it's Free
Speech but you're not allowed to yell
fire in a movie theater that's more or
less the situation okay
so uh even ingest
okay let's move on to the real subject
of today which is
um
Direction
the direction is easy look there it is
there I point right and I have direction
right we're done that was it
see how easy it was
so how did this subject come about
well we have a couple guys that question
this this is what I put on the last
couple times and that's the universal
movie
and why is this movie interesting or
important as a tool
remember it's a tool okay and what it is
is God stops the universe he stops the
watch the clock the universal clock or
the Heavenly clock or the universe just
stops on its own okay nothing moves
anymore not even an electron so
everything stops all motion stops okay
that's the situation here and it's a
good tool because then we can find out
what actually exists in what exists can
be shown in a single frame of that movie
that should show us what exists in the
universe if we had God's eyes we would
be able to see everything that actually
exists right and that's the idea here is
to visualize like if we had God's eyes
what actually exists out there
for that we don't need any motion we
don't need two or more frames of the
universal movie we just need one slice
of time or cross-section of time as I
call it or no motion any way you want to
visualize or imagine it we stop motion
in the universe no more motion no more
time whatever's there is what exists
you're supposed to visualize a static
universe or what I call a frozen
Universe okay that's the idea uh the
tool that I call the universal movie
okay so one fella says the following he
says um explain this mechanism with a
paused movie
well it's the issue is that it's a tool
that's all it is that there's nothing to
explain it's just I want you to make
believe you know um what do you call it
a thought experiment make believe go
through the motions of believing that
you can stop the universe everything in
yours is standing still nothing moves
try to visualize what is in there not
only the visible stuff but also the
invisible stuff remember you got God's
eyes
okay what you think is out there that
you cannot see or touch
okay that's the idea behind the
universal movie uh tool okay and another
fellow says so does Bill think an
instant or durationless moment Universal
frame
is a coherent notion
and again it's just a tool it's it's
um it's used to identify what the
objects what the objects that are there
are you know what is out there okay and
part of the reason is because of this
let me show you this part of the reason
is this uh for the purpose right is that
a lot of people confuse static with
Dynamic Concepts they bring in things
that require at least two frames of the
movie two locations as we talked about
last time
and they think they're talking about a
single frame what's in one frame and
there you have some examples like you
know plasma ether field and energy and
so on
oh those are Dynamic Concepts
okay they're not objects they're not
Standalone physical objects you cannot
point to field
okay because field is something in
motion you cannot point to plasma plasma
is something in motion and it cannot
point to Ether because ether's vibrating
and so on all these are Dynamic Concepts
you need at these two frames in the
movie to conceptualize any of those on
the other hand you have some static
Concepts that you can visualize and
Define and imagine in a single frame and
that's distance location and existence
and the one we're going to talk about
today which is
Direction okay so what does the
universal movie allow us to do identify
the objects Define the static Concepts
okay and differentiate those static
constants from the dynamic ones that's
what that's the purpose of the tool it's
just a tool it's just a handy tool to be
able to relate to what is static what
can be visualized in a single frame that
does not require any kind of motion or
time or whatever any any kind of
movement
okay so uh what's the problem
well
um here it is uh we considered Direction
a static concept you can see it's under
the static group not under Dynamic group
okay
but uh The Establishment the
mathematicians
they believe that direction is a dynamic
concept
and it's defined as a dynamic concept
and everybody has this notion oh yeah go
in that direction
and a direction to get you know what are
the directions to get to City Hall well
you take you go this way and that way
and that way and that way that's how you
get there
and so people have this notion that
direction is the dynamic concept
when it's not we put it under in the
Universal movie we put it under a static
concept A group of static Concepts
that's where the problem starts okay and
it gets quite complicated here okay okay
so here's the definition that you find
out there this is um
I think uh from the yeah from the
Wikipedia and you look up orientation
there and it says directions is a
synonym of orientation
now both orientation and Direction sound
like you know static Concepts in fact
the first line that you'll read says
something along the lines that says the
orientation and I put Direction in there
because it's a synonym and it's also put
in there as one of the possibilities so
it's I have cheated here the direction
of an object is part of the description
of how it is placed okay in the space it
occupies so now they're talking about
you standing in a given you know
location and that sounds like a static
concept so far look so far so good but
then you'll see down the line You'll see
more specifically it refers to the
imaginary what rotation
rotation that is needed to move
the object from a reference placement to
its current placement
now they're talking about Road Direction
being something that moves that that has
to do something with rotation
and uh there you see it's uh a rotation
may not be enough to reach the current
placement it may be necessary to add an
imaginary what translation another
Dynamic concept called the object's
location or position
well how does translation relate to the
location of position when translation is
a dynamic concept and location position
by the by the Same by the the mere words
you know they represent static Concepts
and what they're referring to is ordered
pairs there you see on the bottom right
that's what position is in mathematics
okay so ordered pair is how you get
there okay and you go six steps to the
right and fourth to the north and uh
then you get to the position
and so they're talking about the
translation the fact that you moved from
uh zero zero to six four
okay so that's how it becomes a dynamic
concept and this is a synonym of uh
orientation you know directions the
synonym of orientation so under those
definitions they're Dynamic but then
again they come back as the location
orientation together fully describe how
the object is placed in space that's
again Direction ego static concept and
then again they say the orientation of
an object does not change when it
translates and its location does not
change when it rotates
and you can see the pictures they put in
there they all talk about motion
so what is Direction I thought we all
knew what direction was but these people
are saying that direction has something
to do with motion it's a dynamic concept
so let's uh investigate further and here
you see um some of the sites out there
okay and uh they talk about angular
acceleration and you see in those sites
it says direction of rotation direction
of motion
well what direction is the rotation in I
mean in what direction if if it's
changing the direction constantly
so can we talk about the direction of a
rotation the direction of circular
motion
or irregular motion that's not on a
straight line
so what is this direction that they're
talking about if the direction is
constantly changing
and yeah that's exactly what they're
talking about they're talking about a
change in Direction not about Direction
okay so change is a synonym of the word
motion and so yeah when you say change
of Direction you're talking about the
motion of direction of change
of a changing constantly changing
direction
and the change has nothing to do with
the word Direction that's the point okay
either either direction is change or
direction is Direction static concept
but to say change in Direction and we
have a little bit of a problem there
because uh uh we're referring when we
use that word direction are we referring
to the static concept Direction
referring to the change that's the issue
okay so we go to the Oxford dictionary
and see what they have to say it says uh
world's leading dictionary published uh
dictionary publish sure
um so the direction of course along with
someone or something moves
the course which uh must be taken in
order to reach a destination
and a point to or from which a person or
thing moves or faces
faces can I can accept but moves that's
something else
then you have the dictionary.com says
the line along which anything lies faces
moves
with reference to the point or region
toward which it is directed
okay so when you look at direct because
they use directed to Define Direction
which is already a no no you can't use a
synonym but you look up directions to
guide or show the way to a place
direct to point aim or what send
covered a place or object
so in the best of cases a direction
refers to a static and dynamic Concept
in the worst of case it just reversed at
the dynamic concept which is what most
people have in the backs of their minds
when they think about direction
direction are kind of like the
instructions on how to get there like
position you know the ordered pair it's
how you get there
okay that's more or less the notion they
have and the other thing you should keep
in mind is you know in mathematics
oh they only only deal with Dynamic
Concepts they don't have any use
whatsoever for static Concepts that's
where the problem begins that's why
mathematics became science a synonym of
Science and why science only describes
because that's all that mathematics can
do and what do they describe well they
always start the movie In Motion already
it's already a film strip they never
start at square number one to point to
the objects you know the universal movie
a static frame that's not what they
point to they can't because mathematics
has no use for that that's the issue and
that's how you know mathematics became a
synonym of Science and vice versa
okay so here we have a famous concept of
mathematics that uses Direction okay and
let's find out what this is It's called
velocity
okay and it says speed
and direction
speed is magnitude it's a quantitative
concept Direction on the other hand is a
qualitative concept
so they're going to mix a qualitative
concept that has nothing at all to do
with mathematics and they're going to
blend it in there with speed which is a
magnitude which is a quantitative
concept
but we have more than a little problem
here we have a second problem here
because velocity is for a single point
so when you have a single point you know
uh what is the direction okay here you
have it okay velocity is five miles per
hour okay we already understand that
what's the direction of that point if
it's a single point
I mean if you have an elephant there you
say okay the trunk is pointed in that
direction and it's it was moving in that
direction but when you have a single
point
right because velocity is only for a
given point okay what's the direction
okay how can you imagine how can you
conceptualize direction for a single
point meaning location okay that's the
first problem
okay and here you have the earth going
around the Sun okay
and they say Well it travels at 30
kilometers per second around the Sun
okay no problem
and they say well it's accelerating
and you say hold it I thought you just
said that it's 30 kilometers per second
that doesn't seem like an acceleration
sounds like a constant speed
yeah it's accelerating not because the
magnitude uh you know increased but
because the direction changes the
qualitative component of acceleration is
what
um
changed
okay and so here you see
uh why um why we need to Define this
notion Direction and
realize that it has nothing to do
whatsoever with mathematics
the direction part is the physics part
the magnitude you know they can keep
that that's mathematics but the
direction part that belongs to physics
exclusively
okay and so yeah you look at
acceleration it's a change in velocity
and change in Direction and there you
see uh the definition okay an object
undergoing circular motion experiences
centripetal acceleration okay towards
the center right and uh in circular
motion centripetal acceleration refers
to changes in the direction of the
Velocity but not its magnitude
so we have the component known as
direction right there at the bottom okay
the qualitative part is what changes and
because that changes they call it
acceleration which everybody and their
mother you know they usually uh relate
acceleration as
something that is increasing in speed I
accelerate if you decelerate whether you
decrease your speed so everybody thinks
of speed because that's on a straight
line
but when we have a curves or a curvy
linear path
now they look at Direction you can have
a constant speed but it's the direction
that they say compels the acceleration
okay so this is what you got to keep in
mind Direction now they're introducing
something that does not belong in
mathematics at all
and they call it acceleration which
acceleration seems to imply that
they're referring to an increase in
speed deceleration being the decrease in
speed okay
so keep all that in mind okay but then
we run into some other types of problems
here's one of them okay Stephen Hawking
uh guy who died a few years ago says uh
it goes in there I'm not going to read
all this he says in other words the laws
are the same in the forward and backward
directions of time
we're getting backward directions of
time
what uh direction is that I mean I guess
my forward direction is this way right
but yours you're coming in you're in
opposite direction so which way is time
going is it going my direction my
forward or your forward
so they use these terms
forward direction of time and people
just swallow it they don't catch these
things they just goes through one ear
and out the other
and yeah we have a problem there because
these people are talking about the flow
of time
and that you go forward in time
and it gets worse here you have Mr Brian
green and he says he goes forward to the
future okay it travels to the Future
okay so time uh always goes towards the
futures for some reason you know and
they talk about whether you know they do
all kinds of analysis in the religion of
mathematics about time whether you know
uh it flows in the reverse Direction and
so on down the line you know they talk
about flying to the past or going to the
past say kill your grandfather that kind
of thing you know
um
so we get to all this language stuff
it's all related to language
some of this language does not belong in
mathematics at all some does not belong
in physics like time does not belong in
physics at all we have no use for time
okay because in physics we have to
explain and time can only describe we
have no use for time it doesn't explain
anything okay I cannot explain anything
by saying that the pencil you know fell
to the floor in So Much Time
okay that's a description you know I
need to know what caused it that's what
physics is about not how fast that thing
moved
okay so what do we do well in science
and physics we have to start with
language what people call semantics uh
word salad
uh whatever uh word Wizardry
no it's called or semantic and all these
terms that they use to brush aside all
this because it bothers them you know
they want to use the word field they
want to use the word uh plasma they use
electricity as a physical object just
stick your fingers into the outlet and
you'll find out if it's an object so
that's how they determine if it's an
object they touch electricity it gets a
shock and they say oh that was an object
that was the thing that hit me haha
okay so um we start with language okay
here it is language of physics that's
what we're gonna do we're going to learn
some language of physics that we need to
especially Define
what uh direction is
and so in science we do not do
experiments we do not use math and we do
not make predictions why because science
is about explaining rationally that's
what science is science we explain
that's all we do okay objectively like
we said the other day okay we have to
give an objective explanation for the
purposes of physics right of a mechanism
of a Cause
do you believe it we don't care because
belief has no role in science
I'm not here to convince you I'm not
here to persuade and convert you I'm
here to explain a mechanism so that you
understand it then you go on your Merry
way and think whatever you want
you just need to know or understand what
I'm trying to convey to you my theory of
what I think the mechanism is of gravity
of magnetism of electricity over
whatever
so I explained to your mechanism you
understood it that's the end of science
whether you believe it or not whether I
like it or not that's irrelevant in
science that's religion that's belief
opinion okay so physics rational
explanations of causes and mechanisms
that's what physics is about what the
mathematicians dismiss as philosophy
because they cannot explain that's why
they dismissed it and got it out of
science
and so today they say well that's not
science that's philosophy go to the
philosophers you go to the philosophers
they send you right back they say well
we get our cues from the mathematical
physicists and so whatever they teach us
whatever they that's what we analyze so
you go to the philosophy like you go to
the Stanford encyclopedia philosophy and
they talk about the same exact nonsense
that the so-called physicist quotations
on that mathematical physicists uh what
they talk about
so no International whether you go
one-sided campus or the other they're
all irrational
okay so what uh if you're gonna explain
the mechanism you're gonna need objects
okay and the most basic of words in
physics is the word object thing body
entity figure whatever you want to call
it those are all synonyms okay we use
the word object what is object that
which has shape
people say oh bill please define shape
for me
no we don't want a defined shape sorry
I got you there I got you there
no we don't Define shape because it
means that you didn't understand squat
of what the problem is the problem is
not the word shape the problem is that
if we do not have that definition there
we're going to go with the default and
the default is C touch
that an object is that which you can see
or touch and if you go with C or touch
those are verbs verbs require two two
locations of an object
and so uh it's already so you can't use
those you can't use a verb to define the
word object
okay so you and besides the fact that
you need two objects to do C or touch
anyways it's got to be something that
sees or touches something else
so there are many problems with the seat
touch criteria which is the one
everybody uses because everybody wants
to go and do an experiment in the lab
to see and touch that which is invisible
and intangible so we don't know how
they're going to accomplish that within
any experiment that's why experiments
are not part of science you can do all
the experiments you want no problem but
when you come to the conference we want
an explanation not your stupid
experiment
okay so C touch is the criteria if we do
not go with shea that's the issue we
don't have to Define shape we just have
to know the difference between shape and
see and touch that's it okay or any of
the other some people say it's that
which has mass volume whatever same
thing you got to know the difference
between shape and all the others
as long as you know the difference we do
not need to define the word shape okay
besides you know the um Devil's Advocate
he's gonna you know he's gonna just go
you know and show you that you need more
and more words to define the previous
word than the previous word in the
previous word and that's what they want
they want you to go through the whole
dictionary okay and and just to show you
that see eventually you cannot Define a
word perfectly that's that's their
argument now in science we have to in
physics we cannot leave the conference
room there's eight billion people here
in this conference room we cannot leave
the doors are shut until we Define the
word object because we cannot do physics
without understanding what an object is
okay what the word object you know what
the definition of that word is so we go
with the word shape and that uh goes
against C and touch in other words
against experiments we don't do
experiments to see or touch that which
is invisible or intangible and hopefully
there are invisible intangible objects
out there mediating
gravity magnetism because otherwise
you're doing the your explanation with
black magic
you're saying there's action at a
distance Yeah by What Angels God black
magic
that's the issue so object and shape are
static Concepts both of them and um uh
meth and math Vis you know they don't
use objects okay and it they uh don't
use static Concepts they have no use for
static Concepts all of mathematics and
all of mathematical physics deals with
Dynamic Concepts only exclusively okay
um
let me get this one out of here
so here let's go with one static object
an object that we're going to need to
Define Direction and it's the word line
okay what is line well line is an object
it's a figure
and there you can see it's got shape
it's that blue one a violet violet-ish
one there okay it's an elongated
rectangle that's what a line is
okay and that's objectively what's in
front of your eyes
okay so what do you see there
you see some kind of elongated rectangle
that's a line that we call that a line
okay
how many dimensions does it have two got
width and height you can see that I took
a little piece of it and expanded it you
can see it's got height and width and
it's got uh
four edges I show three there one on the
top one on the uh what is it my right
hand side okay and one on the bottom and
you should imagine on the other side of
the of this stick right they're a 2d
stick there's a another straight line
another Edge so we have four edges the
line is straight and so are the edges
okay we're going to get to that in a
second and the line is continuous okay
what is continuous made of a single
piece conceptually made of a single
piece
okay it's not made of parts now I made a
little pieces it's not mariology
it's made out of a single piece it's
continuous okay and it's finite
like any stick like this one you know
more or less you know it has a beginning
and an end otherwise it would not be an
object
on the other hand you can see the line
of mathematics it's the infinite line
and that's not an object that's an
itinerary
okay it's made of points and at what are
points locations so they're talking
about an itinerary and goes from
negative Infinity to positive Infinity
because they're really trying to put
numbers in there and they say each one
of those points is a number
one third two number are there more
numbers between any two numbers yeah put
as many as you want we can put infinite
numbers between those as well
and chop that up as many pieces as you
want okay so we're talking about not
lines we're not talking about uh a stick
that belongs to physics we're talking
about an itinerary and you know again
it's not an object okay an object is a
line the line is the one that you see on
the top not the one you see at the
bottom okay so let's make sure we
understand that
okay
okay let's move on here and here we have
some definitions that we're going to
need first one is the basic concepts
used in physics
the first one is straight what do we
mean by straight
well straight first of all is an
adjective
and it is a synonym essentially of
Direction in other words it's the
adjective version of Direction
okay but straight as an adjective
whereas direction is not
okay uh in the common usage in ordinary
speech direction is a noun
is not so in physics because only
objects can be nouns in physics you
cannot talk about Direction per se in
physics you know like saying the
direction did this or direction did that
you cannot use it in that term in those
terms cannot be the subject of a
sentence in physics where you're
explaining a mechanism okay but it's a
property it's an attribute you have
attributes like shape which are
intrinsic and you have attributes like
Direction which are extrinsic which
involve other objects
okay so uh we don't have a word for that
because no one ever figured this out
that's why okay so the straight is an
adjective and um it's used to qualify
objects all adjectives are used to
qualify things objects okay
entities
figures okay
straight edge what is that well it's
conceptually 1D
conceptually I underline conceptually
either highlight conceptually because
Edge is not a physical thing okay so you
cannot say it's got you know that the
edge is a thing what the edge is is a
concept that serves as kind of like a
limit to a thing okay so it's a
conceptual but it's conceptually 1D
objects can be one D two d three well
not one D but 2D 3D but Edge cannot be
any D okay no Dimensions can be applied
to Edge but it's conceptually one D I
hope you understand what I just said uh
it's kind of like the line of
mathematics
straight edge uh again it's you could
say it's the synonym of with
okay in that sense that's you could say
it's a dimension I'm going to use the
word Edge for straight edge from now on
so anytime I say Edge I'm referring to a
straight edge it's continuous also what
it continues made out of a single piece
not the edge of your balcony that's not
made out of a single piece okay I'm
talking about the edge that we're going
to use in physics when we point to an
object whatever Edge whether it's
straight or curved that edge is
conceptually made of a single piece okay
it's like the like the object itself the
object is made of a singles piece we
don't care how many atoms make it or uh
if it's made of points or any of that
mariology doesn't play a role in science
that's nonsense invented by the
philosophers so-called philosophers
okay and continues is opposite of
segmented segmented means chopped into
pieces
okay and you can maybe relate go to
people who do some Electronics or maybe
even programming you know you have their
analog versus digital that's more or
less the notion that we have there okay
segmented means made of parts
on the other hand we have axis and axis
is a concept it's not an object okay
it's not a stick really but uh it's a
concept that's not equal to Edge okay so
Edge axis and direction are not synonyms
because they're used for different
things okay the Notions we have Behind
these words Edge has to do with the
limit of an object a border kind of
thing right whereas the axis is you know
around an imaginary stick
uh just uh you can place a line in there
if you want because that's also properly
visualized but the issue is that it's a
a rotation place a place around which
something rotates or spins okay so we
use these things for a different thing
we don't use the edge for that okay
sometimes he adds could coincide with an
axis but not necessarily so
okay so these are the Notions that we
need to learn in order to zero in on our
definition of Direction so it wasn't
such an easy concept to understand
especially when the mathematician thinks
that something in motion okay so here
these are the most popular Notions that
we have today of what a direction is the
course along with something moves aims
or points a line leading to a place or
point or along with something lies aims
or points okay to aim or move along a
line a position to which motion or
another position is referred and the
alignment of two points in space or
their Mutual Mutual angular position or
orientation these are the general
Notions we might have out there
and uh why do I mention these because
from there we are going to try to see if
we can extract the main Notions that
we're going to need to Define this
imagine this even uh difficult word card
called uh description uh Direction now I
just want to point out something that
people say well Direction that's so
simple
why haven't we zeroed in on this
why haven't we zeroed in on the word
object another simple word why haven't
we zeroed in on the word exist another
simple word and I'll tell you why
because it's the simple words which are
the hardest to define the ones that form
your foundation
okay that's why okay and aside from the
fact that we have the wrong people doing
it which are the mathematicians which
have no use for static Concepts and so
all these things you got to keep in mind
okay so here's uh the what we might need
to Define Direction and it's uh two
objects you need two objects to Define
um
Direction and the fact that you need two
objects remember what a concept is it's
a word that invokes two objects or two
concepts or one consonant object treated
as if it were an object okay so you need
uh two things and that's what a concept
is so in that sense direction is a
concept you need two
facing you know uh you have two objects
and like my finger okay and you say well
here's a surface right
and whatever I point to the Moon a stick
a tree a rock whatever I point to that's
got a surface and so there's a face of
that thing facing me and my finger
facing it and we establish some relation
there and we call that uh Direction so
we need facing or the notion of facing
is involved in there okay and we have to
aim right before you point you gotta aim
or pointing is aiming you could say it's
got to be straight
not rectal linear
see some people use the word rectilinear
rectilinear is what we use for motion
right and we say rectilinear least
something is moving rectangularly you
know parallel to a straight line
physics straight rectilinearly well
that's also physique we're gonna talk
about curved Motion versus straight
motion right and so rectal linearly you
could say parallel to straight motion
but what all these people use is
straight path straight motion
straight itinerary no the word is
rectilinear okay you can't use the word
straight you can only use it for objects
not to qualify verbs not in physics in
ordinary speech you can in mathematics
you can not in physics
continuous single piece
it's got to be continuous you can't chop
Direction into two pieces or into
several pieces like the mathematicians
do
you know they have this dotted line
infinite line made of points it's all
chopped into points locations right and
they say that's a line and that line
that one that I just defined is
Direction
no because that's an itinerary
okay we don't use the itineraries to
Define uh Direction because nothing is
moving okay and here
you have the definition okay Direction a
line between two objects what was a line
it was what the mathematicians called
line segment but it's not even that
because this line is not 1D okay it's 2D
okay and that's what we have in
Direction
because we can visualize a line we
cannot visualize a 1D whatever the
mathematicians call the line okay you
can also say that direction is a
straight edge
okay if you're going to use that as more
or less a synonym
uh there's two others I sometimes use
I'm not too confident of those but I'll
put them there anyways Mutual facing of
two objects and direction also line of
sight the problem with God especially
with that last one is that line of sight
people say oh you use cite a verb to say
seeing okay but yeah we're talking about
line of sight so
again you can use any of these the idea
is to get the notion inside your head of
what the definition is you can use any
of those definitions to a certain degree
depending on the context
okay so what are the conclusions here
they are in conclusion or of Direction
okay
static concept yeah first of all it's
not a dynamic concept it's qualitative
okay doesn't belong in math
only quantitative Concepts belong in
math okay
continuous it's made out of a single
piece okay it's straight uh you could
maybe replace it with an edge or an axis
make sure you are very much aware of the
context there okay if you're going to
use the edge of something to say okay
that's my line of sight that's my
direction okay be aware of what Edge the
the context of Edge and axis okay
straight
yeah it's got to be straight okay
distance uh it's essentially distance
with an arrow remember what distance was
separation between two objects
and you maybe illustrate that with a
line two-dimensional line right
segment
okay not a One D lie it's a 2d line okay
that's all you can see okay and we put a
stick there we call it a line and if you
put an arrow well that's Direction
now you see how simple it was and it
requires two objects they have to be you
know facing one face versus the other
face in that sense face facing face face
against face face opposite face
and uh
no Direction between Concepts you cannot
say well I'm moving in the direction of
intelligence
or of love now uh there is no Direction
between love and intelligence
okay so uh when people say time moves in
a certain direction or a forward or
whatever
or um you have counterclockwise or
clockwise what direction
uh no you gotta point to something and
then you're and then you have direction
and you can't point to something if
you're turning the corner okay then
you're not pointing to that same
something
okay so you cannot say that a
curvilinear
itinerary
goes in a given Direction it does in
fact it's changing its direction every
every location
and that's what they call velocity at
each one of those points and the whole
thing is called acceleration if
Direction changes
so uh that's something for you to
sink your teeth in now
okay let's go with our um uh science
critic and here we have a another person
who has problems with um
semantics
word salad
let's see what he's got to say and he's
gonna say here essentially that science
is about winning arguments
winning arguments in other words you
have a discussion with someone else
in the argument
maybe because you beat him up finally
then you're a scientist that's more or
less what he's saying okay and of course
if you're if science is like law where
you have a prosecutor who's trying to
convince the jury you know lawyer out
there well then you're going to need
evidence
right that's one of the issues that
you're going to present
and the other one is that you're not
going to allow the defendant or the
defense attorney there to uh change the
words the meaning of words
because you're going to accuse him and
say ah you're changing the word the
meaning of the words you know instead of
uh murder you call it manslaughter you
know you change the definition here on
us right and so yeah then you then
you're going to win the case just
because you changed the definition of
some word
so are we not allowed to change
definitions especially if the
traditional one that we use the one in
ordinary speech is irrational and cannot
be used in physics we're not allowed to
change that it stays like that forever
because that's the way our forefathers
defined it and used it and that's the
etymology of the word Etc
Okay let's listen to him let's see what
he's got to say here it is our science
critic fingernails okay give me a second
here and put them on go
no questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
is science about winning arguments
and is defining words rationally nothing
but a frivolous exercise in semantics
Bill gate is doing the exact same kind
of thing that Flat Earth is do he's not
trying to win the arguments based on
evidence he's trying to win the
arguments based on semantics when you
try to redefine the entirety of science
to work in your favor then becomes a lot
easier to win the arguments
okay so science is about winning
arguments and for that you have to
present evidence and hopefully change
the words on the on the scientists
uh so that you mix them up and they say
oh you're not allowed to do that bill
you can't change the definitions of
words
those are your definitions of course if
you change the definitions you're going
to win the argument
that's that's a rationale okay and so
here's kind of like the conclusion what
this fellow said science is winning
arguments so I'll let you figure that
out if that's what science is about in
other words
um
science is persuading convincing
converting and recruiting that's what
this follows essentially saying okay
okay if that's what he thinks science is
and of course if you're going to do that
if you want to win the argument of
course you're going to present evidence
like they do in law you know the
prosecutor brings in you know
the evidence to try to persuade the jury
to believe in his side of the case and
his theory and his
um you know in in his argument
and of course if he changes the the
definitions he's got a better chance of
winning the arguments and so it says oh
Bill what you're trying to do is change
the definition so you can win the
argument
well you know we're not into winning
arguments we're here to explain
mechanisms so that you understand a new
definite a new mechanism of how the
universe works and that is that there is
no action at a distance essentially you
know and that uh everything in the
universe is physically physically
interconnected all atoms are connected
so that's the Assumption with that we
explain electricity magnetism gravity
Etc okay and so the issue here is that
we Define words
because they redefine them right because
they've never been defined actually
not for the purposes of science they've
been defined for the purposes of
ordinary speech the mathematicians bring
them into science without any scrutiny
you know and so they they start using
these words yeah and objects that which
you can see and touch and they don't
even pay attention to what they said
partly because they don't need objects
they replace every object with a point
because they're looking at mass or
something else and so they don't you
know or a particle and they say particle
is just a dot just imagine a DOT flying
it's got Mass it's got a charge whatever
and so they don't need they absolutely
don't need the objects and so there are
no objects in phys in mathematics
mathematics mathematics or mathematical
physics for that matter neither one has
objects they don't need objects they
work with points
which supposedly are locations which are
not even locations what they are is
positions and positions in ordered pair
and so on Down the Line so it just goes
on and on and on you never have a
physical object okay so they never
Define words because they never needed
to define words not for not if they're
going to give a physical interpretation
to their equations
okay and so all we have is irrational
explanations physical interpretations
today
because all they want to do is win the
argument
and uh when you put them against the
wall and say well that's irrational and
they say well we don't understand it
either but we've proved it oh you proved
it how did you prove it well because
computers wouldn't work if particles
weren't at two places at once
and GPS wouldn't work if we could not
spend time
those are the types of answers you get
from them
and so yeah
um we have to redefine these words we
have to find out what these words mean
because we're communicating our theories
or physical interpretations
and physical interpretations are part of
philosophy and not a part of physics
why did the so-called mathematical
physics
why did he attempt to give a physical
interpretation to his equation
I mean if he stayed completely within
his world of numbers and equations and
formulas and so on no problem he can do
whatever he wants in there
but he wants to give a physical
interpretation
to his equation for otherwise his
equation is irrelevant has nothing to do
with reality
it's just a description and not an
explanation
okay
okay we have a couple of people who made
some comments and one before says this
Norman wildburgers rational trigonometry
have anything to do with rational
science
well let's look at that word
trigonometry
that's the one we're interested in
because he's talking about trigonometry
and he puts this word rational in front
Okay so let's first find out uh what an
explanation is okay and so here you have
the word explanation according to us
okay the causes or reasons in the case
of philosophy right but physics has
caused this underlying a phenomenon
that's what an explanation is okay
now that's what we use for physical
interpretations okay
and uh another definition how mechanisms
physics or why in the case of uh purpose
for in the case of philosophy uh it it
consummated event happened okay an
explanation deals exclusively with the
past okay and then what is rational well
we needed to Define rational because
people everybody wants to think of
themselves as rational
but then they say irrational things they
start using words like plasma and ether
and uh energy and wave these are
irrational terms especially when they're
used they're irrational because they've
never been defined concisely perfectly
and uh rigorously you know and then on
top of that the worst problem is that
they use these Concepts as physical
objects so that's why they're irrational
so that's the main problem the main
problem is treating Concepts as objects
as things now you start moving these
Concepts around they move all these
souls and conscience and energies and
fields around and that's very scary you
know it's like moving their intelligence
around whatever intelligence they have
uh using inconsistent definitions or
undefined words usually
in fact I think a hundred percent of the
time not usually but 100 of the times
all these words that we've inherited
from our great great great great
grandfathers who misdefined them from
the start because they had no idea what
they were doing
and that's what we have in the
dictionaries today
theory is inconsistent with or doesn't
follow from the assumptions okay make an
assumption and then a theory has nothing
to do with it you know the uh prosecutor
presents a knife says okay uh this is
how the person was killed and then
during the course of
of the um argument or trying to convince
the jury he says and the poison entered
the person's body poison I thought you
said he was stabbed or she was stabbed
so the theory doesn't follow from what
the evidence he presented the Assumption
he presented okay describing and
claiming to have explained and mechanism
proposed doesn't work or cannot even Be
Imagined okay God trying to make a what
squared a circle so to speak okay
okay so
um trigonometry
uh first is not an explanation
and then trigonometry is full of lots of
words that I think are not well defined
okay as long and again if as long as it
stays within mathematics we don't care
but don't bring trigonometry into
physics and geometry
was the first religion because it was an
attempt back more in an attempt to merge
math with physics they had the physical
world that they measured and then they
looked at all these angles and so on you
know sides
and try to make sense of that physical
world
and of course they invented all these uh
abstract objects such as you know uh
point line
uh planes and solids Etc
and and then they looked at angles in
there angles and lengths of sides and
all this kind of calculations that they
did the calculations are okay but then
and if they would stop there then it
would have been okay the problem is then
you get people like Einstein who says
gravity is geometry
oh why is it geometry dear Einstein well
because see we have this space time
thingy
four-dimensional thingy that we cannot
imagine cannot visualize and it bends
well how do you know a Band-Aid if you
cannot even imagine if you cannot show
me a picture of bent
space time on the screen of your 4D not
the 3D not the 2D I want the 4D the one
that you said space time is I cannot
imagine he says
okay so we have a problem because
suddenly a geometry enters the world of
physics and these people are trying to
explain gravity with geometry that's
where we run into trouble that's where
we have irrationality okay and so you
got to be careful with trigonometry
only if you try to introduce it into
physics we have no use for numbers and
we're going to talk about angles at
another time but angles are not what
these people say are angles again
Dynamic versus static Concepts
okay and um
here's another fellow and he says the
following says all satellites are on
balloons
haha and so uh you go to this uh site I
didn't put the site there's a YouTube
site but look up that title and you'll
find it and they say they show that this
uh this transporter of some kind
um uh takes this uh I think it's eight
ton uh
uh maybe I can't remember now but uh
satellite and they show how the balloon
that you see on the right pulls it
upwards and this guy thinks that because
of that oh all satellites are on
balloons that's his argument
uh in the video okay well yeah so these
people again uh they think that
satellites are just being held by a
little balloon
oh my God what a world we live in and
you tell me that it's not the end of the
world yeah sure
okay and here's another fellow says you
need to tell us how exactly every atom
in your body could possibly be bound to
every other atom in the Earth
do you have any idea how many atoms
there are in the Earth
what about in the universe man that's a
lot about them your model is illogical
irrational and downright impossible
okay but we only have one
and that's a single thread there that's
all we have
so that's that's quite simple one
The Nomad
uh we have only one but forget about
that he's contradicting himself he
doesn't even realize it right there he
says you know how many atoms there are
in the universe
uh no could you please tell me
and I guess you would say well it's
impossible it's impossible for there to
be so many atoms in the universe
but he he says like he knew how many
like there's many there's
tons and tons and tons and gazillions
and gazillions of atoms
so what should I answer him that's
impossible there can't be so many atoms
in the universe
right is that my answer so he doesn't
think there's that many ropes because
there's you know you know how many atoms
there are in the universe yeah there's
many many atoms and so there aren't that
many atoms in the universe then because
I cannot imagine that either
so I don't know what's going through
this person's mind but yeah uh our
um basic hypothesis is very simple
there's a single thread
now that's one
close the thread okay uh can you count
to one
that's how many there are
okay with that I'll see you next week
and we'll continue with this line of uh
questioning
we'll see you then bye bye